hello everyone my name uh first of all
thank you for joining me in this talk my
name is Rosie Ruiz and I am tuning in
from California this is my first time
giving a presentation at a conference so
I am very very excited to be here
um yeah I am a junior software engineer
at anaconda and I joined earlier this
year
um and I have been fortunate enough to
be introduced to the Jupiter Community
with a little bit more depth and also
just being a part of of the Jupiter
Community interacting with various
people that are contributing
um to a lot of truly like exciting lines
of work
um and so I want to start off by
mentioning some of the motivation behind
this talk um with sharing this talk with
the pi data Community
um
um and uh so so it starts a little bit
about where New Jupiter notebook stands
um you might find that the title is a
little bit misleading because we'll be
talking about a lot more than jupyter
notebook but
um it is sort of the premise from which
uh it all stems um at least my work and
currently and and uh where we are at
um and so I want to talk about a little
bit about what's happening
um a glimpse of what's coming in the
future and also invite active users of
Jupiter notebook to give their feedback
on some of these tools and and
contribute to Jupiter notebook if you
haven't or Jupiter in general
um I am coming from a place where I had
limited knowledge of the Jupiter
ecosystem and the inner workings of
Jupiter notebook
um and even more so Jupiter lab and uh
so
um I'm becoming familiar currently you
know with Jupiter lab and more areas of
the Jupiter ecosystem so um with that in
mind I hope to stay true to the
invitation that there's no previous
knowledge that is required as I share
some of what
some of the work that many Jupiter
developers are working on but apologies
if that's not the case
um
yeah so
um I'm just going to dive into some of
the changes in the ecosystem
specifically the changes that involve
and be classic as it's the Jupiter
sub-project that has had Anaconda have
been focusing on for the past few months
um so
here is a little bit of an overview of
the agenda today we're going to have a
brief history like the Jupiter ecosystem
and a look at notebook The Notebook
application structure and then we'll
also have a brief look at Jupiter server
and Jupiter lab and that connection with
notebook 7
and how that Jupiter lab development has
motivated development in Notebook and
after which point we will look at Envy
classic uh it's development currently
and and using me classic with Jupiter
lab
okay
oops
go on to the next slide
okay
so uh before diving in further I thought
of course it may be good to revisit some
of the history of Jupiter notebook uh or
Jupiter in general
um so we're gonna go back in time a bit
um there are many pieces that work in
the Jupiter ecosystem
and each have a lot of uh going on
itself themselves and
um there may be a good idea to have some
common like historical understanding of
of what has where we are coming from and
as we look into the the changes that are
to come
um I know that was really helpful for me
and and just learning and and sort of
understanding the the goals of the
developers that are very active in the
Jupiter Community
um
so um as a brief overview of the history
there's before there was Project Jupiter
there was a python which was uh to me
seemed somewhat like a monorepower a lot
of different tools live together uh we
had the interactive shell the rebel
protocol and also the notebook document
format as well as the notebook document
conversion tool and of course the good
old uh web-based uh notebook authoring
tool for
um just for examples these are a few
pieces of the ecosystem
um so all of these tools they were at
different stages of development as well
and they there was a need to be able to
sort of separately uh move forward with
some of them and make new releases as
some were being developed maybe at a
different pace
so some of these pieces were also in
fact not specifically tied to python in
any way
so there's the The Notebook document
format which it will be same regardless
of whether you're coding python or Julia
or R and so really keeping them together
didn't particularly fit so
um a few years back
when what happened was when what it was
called the big split I believe was took
place in the ecosystem eventually
reached the point to where it looks a
lot more similar to what we uh or it
looks a lot more like what we know now
um and that's a separate packages that
we are maybe familiar with uh we have
the NB format package for the notebook
document format and the convert is the
conversion document conversion Tool uh
and of course Jupiter notebook is the
web-based authoring
notebook authoring tool
um so yeah so there are parts of the
Jupiter's act as well that I want to
briefly mention I won't go into too much
today but um it's worth bringing them up
um there is the Jupiter client and the
iPod kernel
um the Jupiter client being sort of the
API which we use to manage and
communicate with Jupiter kernels
um and as well iPad kernel being the
kernel side um
code that provides that IPython kernel
to Jupiter
um there's also Jupiter console which is
a terminal front end for kernels using
the Jupiter protocol
um and um as well there's Jupiter core
which maintains some of the common
functionality that uh many of the
Jupiter uh projects use and so
this is kind of where we stand now this
image might be a
it's probably I think it's a fairly uh
uh recently updated I'm not 100 sure so
I'll have to double check but
um this is a lot going on in Jupiter and
so I just want to uh quickly
um outline those things but we're going
to be moving on right now focusing a
little bit more on the notebook
so for the notebook um just briefly I
want to talk about like the sub project
as we know it
um which starts off like as a trail it's
uh application
um and the trail it's a framework is
what lets the python sort of class have
python classes have like some attribute
to type checking
um some dynamically calculated default
values
um and so really it's it is the sort of
backbone of the configuration of Jupiter
projects
um then if we look uh maybe at the
structure of course we have our front
end our server and and then our kernels
uh if I look at today maybe just for the
purposes of what we'll be speaking about
and the changes that are coming or that
have been implemented in Notebook we can
boil it down to a front-end user
interface and a server with our
application package
um and the front end is comprised of uh
JavaScript HTML and CSS files that are
sort of bundled together
um then the back end is a tornado web
server instance with various handlers
and uh for different mechanisms
um so of course there's a lot more to
unpack there but in the interest of this
presentation we'll leave it at that
um
I do want to mention a little bit too
about the extensions so for
for Notebook extensions we typically
have some maybe JavaScript and c and
maybe some CSS bundled together uh
um or either or
um and the
thing that we use is the package that we
use is the Jupiter NB extensions
configurator server extension which is
what provides sort of the configuration
interface so that it lets us work with
these extensions
um there's also the uh official
unofficial like go-to package for
installing a group of extensions which
is the Jupiter contrib and B extension
package
which installs a collection of notebook
extensions and it's not officially a
part of the Jupiter or organization but
uh it's definitely like widely
recognized within the community so um it
does the server mention
um so yeah so for the notebook we have
here a front end and a server that we
will focus on
um so
then I want to go on to
looking at how another component of
Jupiter is is available to us here
because
um it's another piece of the puzzle that
I didn't really mention in the big split
but it did come soon afterwards
um and that is the Standalone Jupiter
server package
um it started as um a fork of Jupiter no
the Jupiter notebook repository a few
years ago
um and there's actually uh Jupiter
enhancement proposal that was submitted
outlining the details of the goals for
server and uh it's actually great to go
back through that and see how that all
has been implemented today
um so I definitely recommend that to
people that the jeps are are really
insightful
um so personally I found them really
great for for learning about the
ecosystem
um and how it's it's grown and how it's
changed and where it can go
um so yeah
um there were
um with that with this the move uh split
um so they forked this notebook and they
uh removed sort of what was meant to
stay or uh meant to say in the notebook
uh and what was going to be a part of
server um mostly uh what got left in
server was
um essentially handles handlers for
different server management and services
um and for handlers for like file
management for download uh bundling for
kernel specs and auth and and such
um so
another thing too that that that was
really well outlined in the uh the jet
for the Standalone server is the
extension app class which uh allows
server extensions uh to allows to server
Jupiter server to have server extensions
and
um with an extension of course we would
be extending the server endpoints that
are already already available to us um
uh we would extend them with our own
custom handlers for other functionality
there's currently a server extension
cookie cutter that is available and it
starts us off with a lot of the
boilerplate code for the extension
as a
um and so it's very much something I
would recommend if someone is looking to
uh jump into creating some server
extensions I think
um currently there are some changes
going on in server and
um there might be gearing up for another
major release so it's something that um
actually I think they're having a
meeting right now so it'd be
um it's nice to jump in sometimes and
learn about uh what's going on with
server and what updates are coming
um and I think this is a place some some
uh part in
um seeing how the ecosystem has changed
right uh this the split package the
split packaging it allows for things to
grow at their own pace
um and
um as as we can see we uh maybe uh there
are a lot of cool changes coming in in
the next version of Jupiter server
so yeah let me go ahead and now look at
Jupiter lab
um
uh somewhere around the same time that
things uh Jupiter server was coming
around uh Jupiter lab was also
introduced into the Jupiter ecosystem uh
and it is a bit of an IDE uh like user
interface
um so it has a lot more of the modern uh
JavaScript development stack it uses
typescript and react and has been
embraced by many many uh in the
community
it is implemented as a Jupiter server
extension and is all about like
flexibility and extensibility
um so it has it does have a course or
application object but it also includes
a series of like package extensions that
add to that functionality
um so
um for from the document editors to like
the viewers uh to document viewers the
menu system all of that is this is part
of an extension and so um there's a lot
of flexibility there like what you want
to modify what you want to
um uh see in your Jupiter lab
um so
um yeah another so I know here too that
I wanted to point out but I forgot to
edit as a bullet point is that I've seen
a lot of like accessibility talk
um work going on in Jupiter lab so
that's been great to see I of course
wasn't
um around previously to for a lot of the
notebook development so I'm not sure how
um all that all took place and how
common it was but it's been great to see
um that there are meetings and I hope to
join in on sometime on the accessibility
meetings for Jupiter lab
um but let's go ahead and continue
um let's get to notebook 7 which is
um currently if you use uh using jupyter
notebook you'll see you're you're using
a notebook 6 and so
um
notebook 7 is what is coming next it's
the next major version of notebook it is
um it was proposed with a Jupiter
enhancement proposal uh number 79 so um
with uh Jupiter lab being so welcomed by
the community and used so extensively uh
uh it's great but there's no denying
that there are some people that may
still be active users of notebook right
and there are many people who may prefer
a simple or a simpler interface
um much like the one that they're
already familiar with
um previous versions of the notebook
um and so uh this likely maybe plays
some part in the decision the
considerations uh that led to you know
the proposal here at number 79
um for to put forth the release of an
updated uh notebook seven based um on
the more modern uh Tech stack of
um and and sort of uh architecture that
Jupiter lab is based on so the Jupiter
lab components
um and this is all outlined in the jab
uh and so some of the key ideas behind
that took away from that were that the
upcoming notebook 7
um uh we'll use the Jupiter lab
components for the front end and the
Jupiter server for the python server
um and so with that comes the automatic
ability to use the extensions that you
have available for Jupiter lab as a part
of notebook 7
um and um with a small exception of a
few that may not have the same
components in the interface that
notebook 7 has
um that is a much like better experience
right right away than maybe previously
with notebook where there's no really
standard or notebook 6 I should say in
before where there's no standardized
wave but uh
obtaining extensions and and just no
place to well no one place to get them
um and so
um with this incoming change users
installing notebook will soon be
receiving notebook 7
when installed from or Pi Pi are just
doing a simple install we'll bring that
over and and oh well this will soon
hopefully be a welcome change uh with
the updates that it brings
um I think developers do recognize that
there will likely be cases where users
will find potential disruptions to their
workload because of the fact that
um it is a difference
Jupiter MB classic was introduced
and it in me classic it is a
here right so well from earlier on early
on
um when uh Jupiter server was uh
proposed with the Standalone Jupiter
server was proposed there was still a
mention of of both a for a Jupiter lab
interface that is in as an extension of
server as well as a notebook that is an
extension of server right
um
and it's indeed what's happening
notebook 7 is set to be released it's an
extension of a notebook
um hopefully notebook 7 is out in the
near future but um uh although this is
happening there's still um there's still
the fact that a lot of the new
extensions will not be working with the
uh Tech stack
um that uh Jupiter notebook 7 will use
and so
um they will not be compatible and
people will be maybe left with having to
make a choice of maybe I should I can't
move to seven yet or or what is what am
I going to do to make sure that my
extensions are usable in in this new
tech stack and so
um whether these extensions are like
popular extensions within the notebook
ecosystem
um Jupiter notebook ecosystem or
internal extensions that are important
to maybe a more specific group of people
or um a smaller group that uses this
particular extension that is has a lot
of work behind it many years of
development maybe
um so that's kind of where
um our there's been a lot of time and
effort uh spent into like trying to Aid
this transition to the more modern
notebook but
um well like my migration uh guides are
out and they have been available
um but there are obstacles there and
um one of them is simply the new tech
stack um that of course there's other
things that can come up and so uh there
was and is more to do to help smooth
that transition
um and so to help that situation
um
maybe even just giving users more time
to transition to the updated code base
and
um we have the we have Envy classic the
the Envy classic sub project which um
extensions uh developed for Notebook 6
will be compatible with NB classic and
also uh provide the benefit of offering
um through
a means through which users can benefit
from updates on other packages like
updates to Jupiter server
um while continuing to make use of the
old UI that they sort of developed their
extensions for
um so let's go ahead I'm gonna
so uh this is um
a few um sort of uh
big changes or notable changes that I I
wanted to bring up
um I wanted to First go over
um these are changes that have happened
in mb classic so um
uh before I go into depth into a super
like what work has been going on intimid
plastic uh I first want to go over a
small outline of the uh Jupiter server
extension
um so
the Jupiter server provides a base class
Base Class extension app so that
provides much of the boilerplate code
required for a server extension and we
can overwrite
um properties and methods of that class
to fit our needs we can make use of of
uh other tools that are provided by a
jupyter server to set add properties and
um
um work with the handlers that are
available through jupyter server that
the available
um one of the handlers that I'm thinking
of is Jupiter's the Jupiter uh Handler I
believe it is
um which has Jupiter specific settings
so we can uh more easily start working
with extensions
um with the
[Music]
um just want to let you know that you
have five minutes now to take question
answer I would love if you have
to take the questions
oh yes thank you
to ask
yeah if if there are questions uh
please feel free to share um I do want
to share that um I do want to share that
one of the big changes that I wanted to
get to and I didn't get the chance I
want to share before our five minutes
are up uh is that as I mentioned me
classic is there sort of to allow uh
extensions before notebook 6 to work
with uh work in your new environment
where you have downloaded uh notebook 7
and you're working with Jupiter lab
um so one of the big changes that
happened with notebook 6 is that it's uh
now we have a before MB classic notebook
6 and after MB classic notebook 6 before
MB classic notebook 6 is uh 6.4 uh
notebook 6.4 which has its static assets
for the front end to there and it's
still a tornado server
um
and also has the handlers
um but then there's uh the after MB
classic notebook and it's 6.5 which uh
now no longer carries the static assets
they're now provided by MB Classics so
those who are pulled and all that
history was moved over to NB classic and
we have
um still the tornado server and the
handlers within the notebook repo so
um I do want to throw out this head in
6.5 is is
um an enemy classic themselves are meant
to be maintained for the next years
following the release of notebook 7
which will maybe have happened in in the
upcoming few months
um and after then it's intended to just
at the end of life so
um that's an important detail that I
don't want to miss um
yeah
um yes thank you very much
um we have a question here uh by
Francisco
he said any plan to improve the
russianability of I4 mb5s
I'm sorry could you repeat that one more
time it's choppy
or any plan to improve the
questionability of Aqua in Defiance
oh okay I see yeah
um so I think that may be uh some work
that is is happening in Notebook
honestly
um
um I would definitely take a look at the
uh maybe format uh sort of repository
and any issues and conversations that
are happening there
um currently as I mentioned earlier I'm
fairly new to the to the Jupiter
ecosystem and so I'm definitely uh
slowly uh starting off in an NB classic
and now jumping over to look at notebook
7 and uh also Jupiter lab so I'm not
very familiar with maybe going on with
uh sort of uh how notebook files are
virgin but
um I would definitely suggest looking at
some of the other repositories and and
seeing what conversations are happening
in those issues
okay
um thank you very much
we really appreciate you we speaking
with all that credit at Google 2022
yeah so thank you thank you so much for
having me
okay thank you so much I apologize for
not tracking my time uh but thank you
thank you very much for your talk and be
part of my data global 2012. thank you
thank you